all right welcome everybody we're
standing by
for a donald trump vaccine summit
we have been experiencing some internet
issues today
and i really hope that they don't affect
this stream i was worried about that on
saturday night and we were fine
hopefully we will also be fine today
robert sent me a super chat where he
said i wish you would do something to
finish the remaining super chats like a
follow-up video i've been left out
i get it you're doing well and that's
awesome yeah unfortunately you know
sometimes the super chats come in so
fast and furious later on
that you know i would have to spend four
hours answering all of them so they get
up on the screen
and i try to answer many but it's not
always
possible no intro today because i'm
running a little bit behind
there was this really weird moment where
it seemed as though maybe
uh pfizer and moderna would be part of
this summit
and it's going to be a complete
propaganda event will trump where trump
will try to essentially take credit for
these vaccines
that have nothing to do with him and
both pfizer and moderna said
no thank you and i think it's the right
move
um they are currently trying to get
approval for vaccines from the fda
the same fda that's going to be here at
this
vaccine summit so i'm glad modernist
said no thank you
i'm glad kaiser said no thank you
and uh that is a very very good thing so
we're standing by for donald trump the
white house feed
we have a fox news feed joe biden also
uh having an event soon to introduce
some health team appointees
i don't know if you guys saw this it was
very weird
yesterday donald trump um awarded
former wrestler dan gable the
presidential medal of freedom and as it
was wrapping up
peop reporters started asking trump
questions
and trump just sort of like looked
around
and then wandered off and then he left
dan gable
in the oval office to say well he's gone
this is really weird let me get us a
little more volume just so we hear it
properly check this check out how weird
this is
one more question about the inauguration
thank you very much
and off he goes bye-bye
congratulations he's gone he's gone yes
just as quickly as he came he left
and uh really really great comedy
writing i mean you can't write stuff
any better than this really really
strange moment
snorlax is asking me my favorite pokemon
i have no idea i don't know anything
about uh pokemon
um can i take a moment to talk about the
arizona republican party and the rest of
the republicans calling for violence i
haven't seen that
so i wouldn't be able to say i know the
arizona legislative
legislature is shut down because of
rudy's covid jenna ellis also now
got the kovid which is uh pretty wild
and shocking right i mean traveling
around with rudy giuliani
rudy giuliani farting on her four times
during a recent hearing very very
difficult to imagine you know how how
could she possibly have gotten it
um okay what else do i have oh oh oh
here's something interesting
we have so many of these song parodies
now
that i now am maintaining a database
where i can sort by meme
for example so like let's say if we
wanted the massive dumps meme
i would have a number of different
thematic elements here so we could for
example
pull one of them up and then we would
have a song
[Music]
big massive dumps
and then if we wanted a different one i
could say okay we want to stay in the
massive dumps category
but let's instead go to like dj physics
song oh but where is this one
massive dumps here it is this election
was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps
big massive dumps uh in michigan and
pennsylvania
yeah so and then similarly if i wanted
to instead
you know sort by author we could do that
so we could be like okay let's see
like let's see what jethro bradley has
bought us
brought us and jethro bradley had for
example
uh the rudy giuliani fart song as an
example which is a great one as well
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
okay so so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
okay you guys get it so my request to
you is
i'm i'm sure there are songs here there
are songs missing rather
that we've played and i'm trying to
create the master database so if you're
the author of a song that i've played on
stream and it's not here
let me know so i can add it um we also
had
oh uh boner show was another meme and we
have the original clip here this was the
source of that
remind you that we have a tremendous
bonus bonus show
oh boy and that was subsequently turned
into this song by beta zoid
[Music]
oh boy let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh boy
okay so anyway i'm building out this
database i would appreciate your help
uh in so doing because it's a very very
important database to have
okay what else do we have here big thank
you
to a poof's buttock plug
for gifting 10 subscriptions via twitch
and in fact that's a total of 11
gifted during the stream which i very
much appreciate
we are counting website memberships and
twitch subs
towards our goal we also have
uh oh rusty lewis says more songs to
come from rusty lewis oh that's great
amplitude says i heard you play that
voicemail from the guy trashing your
mouth
that hurt my feelings i love your mouth
yeah that's that's
it was an aggressive one let me see if i
have any other voicemails speaking of
which
before we go any further
um oh i actually doesn't look like i do
let me check one other voicemail let me
check the voicemail that jimmy from
philly typically calls into
see if i've got any voicemails there
voicemails let's see here
the the voicemails from jimmy lately
have been cuckoo
cuckoo for coco puffs um
no i just got this this is the latest
one from him
david jimmy from philly i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired and listen to your
[ __ ]
about unhinged trump supporters and this
and that
why don't you and i have a little debate
on what's really happening you can't you
you you you can't withstand it david
you're so full of [ __ ] so obviously
deceitful
you make me sick david
i i got my hat's off to you that you can
this guy doesn't like unhinged people
right [ __ ]
over a million people and most these
people don't even
research anything you say they don't
refute it at all
so you can basically when you get that
kind of feedback
or non-feedback or whatever you can
[ __ ]
basically dictate whatever the [ __ ] you
want
right congratulations david
that in itself is a feat you are the
the 2020 winner of deceit
yeah my information [ __ ]
[ __ ] your cappuccino and that last line
about my cappuccino
was actually turned into a song parody
as well let me see if i can find
if we sort by theme here
i should have a jimmy from philly area
here it is caller jimmy from philly
cappuccino and so we got this out of it
i've not listened to this let's listen
to it together
and and see what it what it's
david about from philly i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired and listen to your
[ __ ]
about unhinged trump supporters and this
and that
make yourself full of [ __ ] right i got
my hat's off to you you can't you
you you can't withstand it david
you got my information [ __ ]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[ __ ] your cappuccino so very very
powerful track ominous in a way i would
even i would even argue
uh okay so we got that and then i also
want to say thanks to stephanie
mourion who is new member number 12
today at joinpacman.com
very much appreciate it okay chakuseki
who's a physician
says david be careful if you get coveted
you may never have a boner show again
because of newly discovered side effects
protect your cuke for only fans yeah
that is um that is important and we even
have i even think i have the only fans
call yeah check this out this was a
funny call i got the other day
very forward uh uh viewer who was um
you know making making very important
points right away take a listen hey
david it's me
um i just was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making an only benz
well sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh gardening season is over and it's
time for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks to be
perfectly frank flippy
that works too yeah uh no but i am on
cameo which i think is like the work
safe only
fans right well that works well thank
you
and by the way where does the name
flippy come from
oh just an alias online oh does it have
any meaning
no does it relate to like a floppy disk
for example
remember those five and a quarter
inchers oh it's supposed to be like
flippy floppy like a stupid way to call
flip-flops
oh i got it by the way are you cleaning
a violin in the background
i know it birds sorry oh it's bird okay
um all right very good well listen i
really i really appreciate the call
so that was a pretty strong moment on
the show very very interesting
and uh yeah appreciate it mommy chickson
has subscribed on twitch and says trump
tried to cheat in pa
but didn't have enough votes he won but
millions
he won but millions okay also thanks to
an anonymous gifter for gifting
10 subs on twitch which puts us at plus
13
also known as 25.
um other super chats talk about the
texas lawsuit a bit i did not see the
texas lawsuit so i don't i'm not sure
about that yet
got to get caught up on a lot of these
elements
superficially speaking having 13
justices would also be poetic given our
nation was comprised of 13 colonies
fair that's interesting i've come around
on the idea of expanding scotus
preferably adding
four to get a democratic majority
interesting
david i heard that pompeo's christmas
rager
now sports an eggnog ice luge and an ann
coulter-esque stripper named candy cane
be aware of mistletoe beware of the
mistletoe i didn't hear that
and bolo turner says love the new
profile picture david
this message brought to you by radical
liberal raphael warnock i'm fighting for
the american dream
oh i have a clip of that as well
i don't know if you guys remember we
watched many of us watched that debate
together
on sunday and it was really weird
check this out um
oh no that's in it oh here it is yeah
check check out the repetition the crazy
of one of our viewers made this
this was the debate the other day deal
i'm fighting for
chuck schumer chuck schumer chuck
schumer's chuck schumer chuck schumer
chuck schumer chuck schumer chuck
schumer chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi to live the american
dream the american dream of the american
dream the american dream the american
dream the american dream
the american dream of the american dream
the american dream the american dream
the american dream the american dream
the american dream
the american dream and the agent of
change is my opponent
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal rafael warnock
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock radical liberal
raphael warnock
radical liberal rafael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock radical liberal
raphael warnock radical liberal raphael
warnock radical liberal raphael warnock
radical liberal raphael warnock radical
liberal rafael warnock radical liberal
rafael warnock radical liberal rafael
warnock is their agent of change
but all those things that you're warning
about would not be happening presumably
with this is not repeat by the way
president trump is president so it
almost sounds as though you're conceding
that that part of it has been settled
and now it's important for the
republicans to
to keep the majority in the senate to to
have a divided government
i was born and raised on a farm i was
born and raised on a farm
i was born and raised on a farm i grew
up working in the fields
i grew up working in the fields i grew
up working in the fields i waitressed my
way through school
i waitressed my way through high school
and college and i was the first
in my family to graduate from college
and i was the first in my family to
graduate from college
i'm kelly leffler i'm a threat to our
children there's okay that last thing
was an edit i'm a threat to my children
she really she didn't really say that so
very very interesting stuff
uh very nicely done very very nicely
done big thank you to shot
x thomas who has subscribed with prime
and says
the american dream quoting kelly leffler
who really deserves to lose
also big thank you to linda lobo who has
subscribed
at joinpacman.com and is a our newest
member
just a very quick reminder
the best way to support the work we do
right above my head
join pacman.com coupon code fresh start
it's that simple my friends
joinedpakman.com coupon code fresh start
a lot of people
sadly and this is very very sad
having to cancel memberships because of
kovid it pains me to see it one example
is alex
who wrote to me look at this from alex i
am sorry
good evening mr pakman so formal it's
unfortunate but i have ended my
membership at least for now because i
have been unemployed since
march and my family and i are unsure
when we'll feel it's safe
for me to be in a real-life workplace
again i will remain subscribed
to the show's youtube channel i'm sorry
um so a lot of people having to cancel i
would love it if you
joined at joinpackman.com
i will announce names as we will hear
from
prump apparently a video not live over
here yet
kids coming in and i don't know what's
going on to be honest
it looks like we don't even have live
video yet or live audio rather
you told the american people that we
would have a vaccine before the end
oh my god what a propaganda event some
scoffed at that timetable
the vaccine by the end of this year is
that possible in your view
oh brian you know it's another day of
potus in wonderland here uh
it is preposterous could be january
could be later we don't know so the
whole process
is going to take a year and a half at
least they're certainly not going to be
ready to start poking people in the arms
real soon
i still think 12 to 18 months is an
aggressive schedule and i think it's
going to take longer than that to do
there's no prospect that there's going
to be a vaccine available for the
majority of the american people before
the middle of next year
it is impossible to get that done by the
end of the year
operation warp speed is unequaled and
unrivaled anywhere in the world this is
wild single greatest mobilization
thanks anna for the membership and
manufacturing therapies and vaccines
in record time operation warp speed is
doing something that's never been done
before in history the first americans
will get shots in arms
in the second thanks alex as well
december that's incredible
elizabeth the timeline has just been
jaw-dropping we were able to and
empowered to make has a vaccine ever had
a trailer dramatic
movie trailer before it is true this is
warp speed warp speed is being run in a
non-political way
in a way we can be proud of we believe
we're gonna have people getting
vaccinated
millions of people before christmas this
year it's just
unheard of in the history of public
health
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
oh my god this is weaponized
[Applause]
good thing moderna and pfizer refused to
be here if they had been here
it would have been sick i respect them
for saying no
thank you very much please
thank you very much appreciate it very
much i'm honored to welcome doctors
scientists
industry executives and state and local
leaders to our historic
operation warp speed vaccine summit it's
been some
journey for all of us what has been an
incredible success
we're grateful to be joined by vice
president mike pence who has done
an absolutely incredible job on the
coronavirus task force mike thank you
stand up mike
imagine cheering pence
we're here to discuss a monumental
national achievement
from the instant the coronavirus invaded
our shores we raced into action to
develop
a safe and effective vaccine oh my
goodness next speed
it would normally take five years six
years seven years or even more
not with an mrna achieve this goal we
harness the full
power of government the genius of
american scientists and the might of
american industry to save millions and
millions of lives all over the world
we're just days away from authorization
from the fda
and we're pushing them hard shouldn't be
pushing them let them do their job
mass distribution before operation warp
speed the typical time frame for
development
and approval as you know uh could be
infinity
yeah and it's because we have a
different vaccine platform you guys know
that
things done at a level that nobody has
ever seen before
the gold standard vaccine has been done
in
less than nine months on behalf of the
entire nation i want to thank everyone
here today who has
been involved in this extraordinary
american initiative i
also want to recognize members of my
administration who have worked
tirelessly
in this effort uh alex azar please alex
where is alex alex azar that's hilarious
and it never should have happened bon
jeff slowly where are you monster
thank you very much great job
a man who's now going to be very
important general gus
perna i have no doubt about it right
logistics jared kushner's worked so hard
where's jared
kushner what did he have to do with it
dr deborah burks deborah
is this like the mission accomplished
moment
admiral brett gwar where is brett
gwar great job you've been doing brett
surgeon general jerome adams jerome
thank you very much terrific dr robert
redfield
robert thank you very much appreciate it
imagine we have four percent of the
population 25 percent of the deaths and
they're declaring this over before
anyone's been vaccinated it's it's
mental illness it really is
peter thanks peter thank you
paul mango adam bowler and brad smith
thank you
i didn't know paul mango was involved i
thought it was stephen papaya who
actually did it
incredible job and and many others also
many many others
we're also grateful to be joined by
governors greg abbott
who is greg
billy phil
thank you if paul mango's there tim
apple better the hell be there
ron desantis ron
thank you ron thank you thank you very
much great job ron
and john bel edwards john bell
thank you thank you john doe thank you
very much
as well as senator john barrasso who's a
fantastic
doctor also by the way i have to say
trump announcing a vaccine for something
that's not serious like the flu but he
won because they finally got the vaccine
even though it's not necessary and his
supporters won't take it
great win that was easier than you
thought it turned out right
it was a little easier than you thought
great going we're proud of you
congressman greg
walden greg thank you very much thank
you very much
and congressman brad wenstrup thank you
brad
great job and many many others
my administration provided a total of 14
billion dollars to accelerate vaccine
development
neither modern or pfizer took it the top
candidates in advance
long in advance as a result of this
unprecedented investment
we are exceedingly proud that both
pfizer and moderna have announced that
their vaccines are approximately 95
effective which is a number that nobody
expected to be able to get to
far exceeding anything that really we
that anybody thought we
went out and we said what do you think a
maximum would be and i think
doctors we all came up to the conclusion
that something like that would be
really incredible we have other us
candidates looking right now
we have uh some big ones we're going to
be announcing very soon we have some
companies great great
companies out there you all know about
how is the uk already vaccinating people
they're all coming in and they're coming
in very quickly we expect to have some
news on that very shortly
and we have worked work very well with
the companies but if for any reason
we have any problems we will be
instituting the defense
production act and we will make sure
that we don't have any problems for very
long we've instituted it before two
additional
companies astrazeneca and johnson and
johnson
as you know the johnson johnson's a one
dose
one-shot vaccine so we're going to see
how that works that would
be very helpful if that all came out and
i think it probably will also
they're showing tremendous uh tremendous
promise
all of them tremendous problems we're uh
we're very hopeful that the fda will
authorize the fisa vaccine within days
we've got to get it moving and modern
our vaccine
almost immediately thereafter large
numbers of tests and samples have been
done
so hopefully that will go very quickly
if authorized tens of millions of
vaccine doses will be massive vaccine
dumps
and we'll get it distributed very
quickly we have that all set and
hundreds of millions more will quickly
follow every american who wants
the vaccine will be able to get the
vaccine
and we think by july spring we're going
to be in a position that
nobody would have believed possible just
a few months ago
[Applause]
one person felt stronger about it
they say it's they say it's somewhat of
a miracle and i think that's true
they do don't they forward prioritizes
the elderly and patients with underlying
conditions when trump said we were
coming out
on easter he meant easter of 2021.
ultimate decision rests with the
governors of the various states
and i hope the governors make wise
decisions who will decide
where the vaccines will go in their
state and who will get them first we
urge the governors to put america's
seniors first and also
i think those who work with seniors
which obviously you
gonna have to do that i think they have
to go together
and doctors nurses first responders etc
this will quickly and dramatically
reduce deaths and
hospitalizations and within a short
period of time i think
uh we want to get back to normal a very
standard phrase we want to just get back
to normal get back to where we were
a little more than nine months ago we're
doing incredibly
and in many respects we're still doing
incredibly with our stock markets and
everything else which are hitting
all new highs we've already finalized a
partnership with walgreens and cvs whose
executives join us today thank you very
much for being here thank you very much
we appreciate it very much
and they will deliver vaccines directly
to nursing homes as soon as
the state's request that they do so
later today general gus perner will
outline the detailed plan to rapidly
distribute the vaccine to every state
territory and tribe
states have designated over 50 000 sites
that will
receive the vaccine we've worked very
closely with the states actually
we've had very good relationships with
the governors i
almost think all of the governors at
least in those conference calls that are
somewhat secret other than sometimes on
occasion mike the press will break in
which is fine too
it's amazing how do you hear that guy in
the background
seconds later there wasn't even time for
a leak they were on the call
but that's all right so you assume that
you always assume that
but they'll be going through pharmacies
hospitals healthcare providers
through our partnership with fedex ups
and mckesson we'll ship doses from
warehouses directly to the designated
sites and
we're thrilled to be joined by
representatives those really great
americans do we know if hefzepha hyde
will be participating
incredible to work with and i want to
thank you all for being here please
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much
as i've stated all along and i guess as
you saw pretty vividly i heard about the
uh
i heard about what they were going to
show prior to my
coming uh you saw that very few people
thought that this was possible
uh of course they'll be saying now we
always told you it was so but
we have them saying a little bit
different but uh it has been
it's funny because all along what
science has been saying is
approval by the end of the year some
doses in december
no widespread spread availability until
q1 or q2 it and we're still there
and that's very important we work with
the world we're working with the world
we have great companies and we're
working with the world
in just a few minutes i'll sign an
executive order to ensure that the
united states government
oh prioritizes the getting out of the
vaccine too i'm going to talk to you
guys about this sending it to
other nations now if necessary i told
you we'll
invoke uh the defense production act
but we don't think it will be necessary
if it is it's right people in the chat
are pointing out
pfizer offered them more doses at the
end of the summer and trump said no and
now pfizer's like well okay
we'll give it to other countries who
have bought it and now trump's going to
try to use an executive order to figure
out how to get more doses it's
every everything is a tragedy of errors
quality rate by
85 think of that 85 percent
it's an incredible number i've delivered
on my
solemn promise to make the antibody
treatments they're brilliant they're
highly successful
it's unclear they work to every american
and we're doing that
free of cost so we're making them
available
and they're available now and if
somebody gets sick
it works where they go and they get
treatment
if that's what the doctors are
prescribing
and it's been incredible the success and
when you hear 85 percent
that's some number to me that's a number
that goes along with anything else
including the vaccines when you think
about it as well as it goes with fries
it goes with squash it goes without five
percent uh people
people find that one hard to believe but
you look at the stats and you see what's
happening
and you look at other countries they're
having tremendous difficulties in europe
tremendous beyond
relatively beyond what somehow they're
vaccinating people already
but this will vanquish the the problem
this horrible scourge as i call it the
china virus because that's where glory
from
and the virus uh has really uh
been looked at and studied all over the
world and our scientists are industrial
and economic
they've looked at the vitalization has
been like nobody else in the world could
have done
this is pretty meme worthy i'm not going
to lie they've looked at the virus
and other nations i've worked and
invoked the defense production act
over 100 times to manufacture essential
supplies in the united states
despite the grim projections from the
media eight months ago where they said
this was impossible they actually said
and
you saw that a little bit but i could
give you uh
two hours worth of it uh please don't it
will never happen you could never do it
it was a pipe dream
but we we did something that nobody
thought was possible and we also did it
where no american who has
needed a ventilator has been denied a
ventilator
uh when we when this first came out we
weren't
equipped for that nobody was equipped
for that and we're now making
ventilators and uh
we have all we need in this country but
we're sending them to countries all over
the world
countries you've never even heard of
thousands of ventilators a month the
united states has also created the
largest most advanced and most
innovative testing program in the world
by far
we've conducted over 200 million tests
think of that 200 million tests
more than all of the european union
combined it's not even close
just 10 months ago none of these
innovations even existed the tremendous
progress that we've made is a testament
to what
our nation is capable of when america is
faced with a challenge
we come through and we always come
through to overcome every hardship and
surmount
every obstacle and i think you'll be
seeing that over the next few months
uh the numbers should skyrocket downward
he'll be gone
we are the most exceptional nation
negative skyrocket
today we're on the verge of another
american medical
miracle and that's what people are
saying people that aren't necessarily
big fans of donald trump are saying
whether you like him or not
this is one of the greatest miracles in
the history of
remind me what trump did to get these
vaccines any other medicine any other
age of medicine
american companies were the first to
produce a verifiably
safe and effective vaccine together we
will defeat the virus and we will soon
end the pandemic and we will save
millions and millions of lives
both in our country and all over the
world maybe billions go already started
thank you again to every person here
today and
for the incredible achievements uh that
you've done you're going to be very
proud of this day and you're going to be
very proud of this period of time
because nobody thought this was possible
nobody thought it was
even remotely possible to do what we've
done in
a period of less than nine months
something that
just not uh even thinkable and
we took a lot of heat when we said this
is our goal and we frankly weren't
even quite uh using the numbers that we
used we far exceeded what we thought if
we made up numbers
sometime next year i think most people
would have said that would be great that
would be a miracle
but we did it long before sometime next
year so now i want to
ask several leaders who have been
crucial in this effort to join me on
stage
as i signed the executive order to
ensure that american citizens have
his readings extra bad today crucial and
stuff like that it's weird
and then we're going to be working with
other countries all over the world and
i think we'll be able to start doing
that almost immediately also because we
have millions of doses coming in
so uh thank you very much thank you it's
great honor
wow is he gonna be at a tiny desk again
the funny thing is what he's signing has
nothing to do with the development he's
signing something to try to get more
vaccines for the us
and fewer for other countries but like
the signing has no relevance to getting
the vaccines approved
is he gonna hold it up and do
so that see here i guess we have to do
our vice president
those are just unused sharpies
[Applause]
there it is wow
nobody knows what he signed do i'll
explain to you what he signed it's
actually pretty sick i'll explain it in
a moment
any questions please oh questions
will you admit you lost will you go to
the inauguration
oan please
any questions please question yes
what your message please for the
american people given all the increasing
cases right now
about what they should do over christmas
and
the hardship that they're all facing i
think that's jeff mason from associates
from a reuters
puts out their guidelines and the very
important guidelines but
uh i think this i think that the vaccine
was our
goal that was number one because that
was the way
uh it was the way it ends plus you do
have an immunity you develop immunity
over a period of time and
i hear we're close to 15 percent i'm
hearing that and that
what is terrific that's a very powerful
vaccine in itself
and just tremendous progress has been
made uh
one of the reasons we do show so many
and i say this and i've been saying it
for a long time so many cases
is because of the fact that we have 200
million tests and
you take uh i think india is actually in
second place with just a fraction of
that number
so we're uh many times greater than the
size i guess if it's 3x infections 1.4
billion people
where our testing program has been
incredible
and we actually are also coming out with
new tests very shortly that will make
the process
even feels like june again and you won't
need doctors necessarily to do the test
so
we have some incredible tests coming out
in a very short period of time
yeah please president most of these
scientific officials here in this room
have encouraged americans
not to travel this holiday season not to
go to large gatherings
across the street you've been holding
holiday parties with
hundreds of people many not wearing
masks why are you
modeling a different behavior to the
american people
well they're christmas parties and
frankly we've reduced the number of
earth substantially oh if it's christmas
go ahead oh party's wearing masks i mean
i have i would say that
the virus respects jesus audience at
those parties we have a lot of people
wearing masks
and i think that's a good thing yeah
please uh
over here the next administration will
be the one ultimately that implements a
lot of the distribution of this vaccine
and will oversee
much of the future of the way operation
warp speed goes forward why not include
members of the biden transition team
as part of this summit that you're
hosting today well we're gonna have to
see who the next administration is
because
we won in those swings oh god uh there
was
uh terrible things that went on so we'll
have to see who the next administration
is but
whichever the next administration is
will
really benefit by what we've been able
to do with this
the doctors all in one people that came
up the lab technicians the work
the work that's been done is incredible
and it will be incredible for the next
administration
and hopefully the next administration
will be the trump administration
because you can't steal hundreds of
thousands of votes
you can't have fraud and deception and
all of the things that they did
and then slightly win a swing state and
you just have to look at this
the curb it's been on tape look at all
the corruption
and we'll see you can't win an election
like that so hopefully the next
administration
will be the trump administration a
continuation which has led us to the
highest stock markets we've ever had the
best employment numbers we've ever had
a rebuilt military if you look at
the tax reductions are the greatest in
history the regulation reductions the
greatest in history
it leads us to space force which nobody
thought was possible space force one of
the things we've done
questions about him losing he's talking
about space force let's see whether or
not somebody has the courage
whether it's a legislator or
legislature's
cure whether it's a justice of the
supreme court or a number of justices of
the supreme
ors courage to do what everybody in this
country knows
is right i received almost 75 million
votes the highest number of votes in the
history of our country for a sitting
president
12 million more than the 63 million
we received four years ago president
obama received 3 million
less in his second term and he won
easily i received 12 million more which
by the way is a record
what a [ __ ] and they say
that when the numbers came out and the
numbers came through machines and all of
those ballots were taken away and
added all you have to do is turn on your
local television center you see what
happened
with thousands of ballots coming out
from under tables
with all of the terrible things you saw
all you have to do is take a look
he can't help himself if somebody has
the courage i know who the next
administration will be
and i'll tell you what life will be much
easier for this country because of what
we've done
if someone will steal it for him he'll
be president of the people in this room
the job you've done
on the vaccine together with a lot of
others has been a modern day
miracle and it's really been
acknowledged as such and i want to thank
thank you very much everybody and i want
to give you my thanks because you're
very special people and now
good luck you distribute that general
and really set records okay set records
just like we have no supplies
thank you very much thank you everybody
thank you wow
what a it would be a comedy if it
weren't a tragedy you know
[Applause]
he really should be played out with a
song right i mean
[Applause]
right now angels are being dispatched
they're coming here
okay anyway so that's going on uh let's
check in now with joe biden's event very
important event
driven always by science and facts
by head and by heart i believe
this is vivic murthy who will be the new
uh surgeon general
where the grandson of a poor farmer in
india
could be asked by the president-elect to
look out for the health of an entire
nation
that is a testament to the promise of
america
one that i will seek to fulfill every
day as surgeon general
yep thank you so much and thank you
again mr president-elect
and madam vice president-elect for this
opportunity to serve
wow
sanitization happening there we've got
joe biden we've got kamal harris that's
dr vivek murthy
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i am honored by the trust you have
placed in me to serve the american
people during this critical time
i want to thank my amazing husband and
our three wonderful sons
for answering this call along with me
as all doctors and public servants know
these jobs ask a great deal not only of
us but of our families
the pandemic that brought me here today
is i believe this
is dr rochelle walensky mgh
chief of infectious disease who will run
the cdc she'll be replacing dr robert
redfield
hiv aids crisis as a medical student
i saw firsthand how the virus ravaged
bodies
and communities inside the hospital
eyewitness people lose strength and hope
it is well outside the hospital i
witnessed those same patients
mostly gay men and members of vulnerable
communities
be stigmatized and marginalized by their
nation
and many of its leaders a scientific
breakthrough came
in 1995 when the fda approved the first
aids cocktail and we saw the first
glimmers of hope i've dedicated my
career
ever since to researching and treating
infectious diseases
and to ending the hiv aids crisis for
good
now a new virus is ravaging us
it's striking hardest once again at the
most vulnerable
the marginalized the underserved
nearly 15 million americans
have been infected over
280 million loved ones
are gone the pain is accelerating
our defenses have worn down i think she
meant 280 000 losing life
and hope at an alarming rate
i never anticipated i would take on a
role helping lead our national response
and government service was never part of
my plan
but every doctor knows that when a
patient is coding
your plans don't matter you answer the
code
and when the nation is coding if you are
called to serve you
serve you run to take care of people
to stop the bleeding to stabilize
to give them hope and a fighting chance
to come back
stronger that's what doctors do
i'm honored to work with an
administration that understands that
leading with science is the only way
to deliver breakthroughs to deliver hope
and to bring our nation back to full
strength
to the american people and to each and
every one of you
at the cdc i promise to work with you
to harness the power of american science
to fight this virus and prevent
unnecessary illness
and deaths so that we can all get
back to our lives mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect i thank you
for this opportunity
shouldn't she be insulting someone or
attacking somebody's character maybe
i'm this is so weird rochelle walensky
from here in boston
we'll run the cdc madam vice
president-elect
thank you so much for this opportunity
to serve the american people
i'm proud to go to work with leaders who
are deeply committed to science
and to centering equity in our response
to this pandemic
and not as a secondary concern not as a
box to check
but as a shared value wove it into all
of the work that we do
and prioritize someone's whispering
remember of the biden harris team
i'm enormously thankful to my research
team
and to my colleagues to president
salovey
and the other leadership here at yale
for supporting me in this work
and i'm grateful to all of the
researchers and advocates
who've blazed the trail whose work on
health equity
and racial justice too often went
unbelieved
or overlooked across the generations
most of all i'm thankful to my family
to jesse and our three children for
their unwavering
support and humor and to my mother
and her mother for modeling kindness
generosity and courageous leadership
through service i have wanted to be a
doctor since i was
six years old and i'm a proud general
internal medicine physician today
but as i grew up i came to understand
that there were deeper dimensions to
health beyond what i saw in the human
biology textbooks
that i borrowed from my mother's
bookshelf
i grew up on saint thomas in the u.s
virgin islands
a place where people too often die too
young
from preventable conditions
my own father had his first stroke in
his 40s
and was left paralyzed i learned there
was a term for what we were
an underserved community marginalized
by place and by race
in my medical training i saw countless
patients
whose conditions were shaped by factors
having nothing to do with science
and everything to do with broader social
inequity
and now the kovit 19 crisis has laid
those inequities
bare it is not a coincidence
and it is not a matter of genetics that
more than 70
of african americans and more than 60
percent of latin next americans
personally know someone who has been
hospitalized
or died from coven 19.
the same disparities ingrained in our
economy
our housing system our food system our
justice system
and so many other areas of our society
have conspired
in this moment to create a grief gap
that we cannot ignore
it is our society yeah i see people
talking about latinx
i as many of you know i'm latino i it's
not a term that i use
um for both linguistic and and cultural
reasons but
probably not the top subject right now
as we emerge from this crisis and
rebuild
including for those most marginalized
communities
the undocumented the incarcerated the
homeless
i'm grateful for this chance to continue
this work
to earn trust and to find success
through genuine partnerships
with the people and communities who've
been hit the hardest
during and before the crisis
on this team you will be heard
you will be counted and you will be
valued
thank you
wow
president-elect biden and vice wow
here we go thank you so much for asking
me to be part of this covid response
team
chief medical advisor that you don't
mind that our reason that i am sending
this video
is because a close friend and colleague
at the nih
dr harvey alter is receiving the nobel
prize in medicine
at the same time and we wanted to attend
the ceremony at the nih
wow to show our support such an
achievement
is a reminder of the incredible public
servants
we have at the nih and of america's
place
as a pioneer in science and medicine
i believe as you do that in the fight
against this pandemic
we must lead with science and that a key
piece
of our ongoing work is communicating
consistently
with the american people whether it's
maintaining social distancing
and not congregating indoors or the
100-day
challenge you described on masking
trump's not going to
work to get as many people vaccinated as
possible
these actions are bold but they are
doable
and essential to help the public avoid
unnecessary risks
to help us save lives reopen schools and
businesses
and to eventually beat the pandemic
i look forward to advising you on these
most urgent priorities
and to work with this team of
world-class experts
whom i have known for many years and
deeply respect
i have been through many public health
crises before
but this is the toughest one we have
ever faced as a nation
the road ahead will not be easy
we have got a lot of hard and demanding
work to do in the next
year but as we have done during previous
crises
i also know we can get through this
pandemic together
as a nation thank you for giving me the
opportunity
to be part of this effort together
one more cleaning
turning the page
beautifully done
president-elect biden and vice
president-elect harris
i'm honored by your trust in me and
humbled
by the task at hand and i am hopeful
because of your leadership as it is for
both of you
everything starts with family for me and
i am forever grateful for the love
and support of my wife our children
and our parents mr president-elect we've
known each other for a long time
anyone know who this is and our
relationship has been forged
under immense pressure the severity
of the great recession the challenge of
implementing the affordable care act
and the daily decisions a white house
makes that affect the lives of millions
of americans
you and president obama knew how to
build a team
with the right diversity of backgrounds
and views
a team to make progress on difficult
situations
and capture enormous opportunities
that's what i've tried to do throughout
my career
i'm not a doctor or a public health
expert
in fact we've got the best ones in the
world
on this team this is jeff zince
kovidzar kovitzar incoming
and the key part of the role you've
asked me to take on
is the last part coordinator
it's about empowering experts developing
a culture of teamwork and maintaining a
focus on strategy
and execution it's knowing that
leadership requires
expertise transparency
and prioritization it also requires
trust truth and integrity
low energy guy but competitive people
that's what this team will provide
we will utilize the full capacity of the
federal government
to get this pandemic under control
to harness and examine the data to
expand
testing to deliver equipment
and ppe to those on the front lines guys
i get that is suit and tired terrible
but
competence is what we care about here to
operate safely
to address the racial disparities and
inequities
of this pandemic to rejoin the global
fight
against covet 19 because no one is safe
until everyone is safe
and with our collective expertise we
will oversee the rollout of the vaccine
which is the president-elect said will
be one of the greatest operational
challenges
our country has ever faced
and we also will pull the country
together
across governments at the federal state
and local levels
and across the private sector
and as we begin this work mr mr
president-elect
i remember what you told me when we were
implementing the affordable care act
your message was i know this is
no small task i know it's not like trump
suits make any sense either there's
pressure to succeed
and we want and need the team to pull
this off
you then said i know you and the team
can do this
but i need to promise you promise me one
thing
that you will always always
give it to us straight because we have
to understand the challenge
we're facing because most of all
we're in this together and together
we can do this president-elect biden
vice president-elect harris and the
american people
this team will always give it to you
straight
the work ahead will not be easy
but we know what needs to be done and we
will get it done
together thank you
wow
and a another cleaning of the lectern
and we will hear from uh vp elect kamala
harris
well congratulations mr president-elect
um on nominating and appointing a most
outstanding team
to get this pandemic under control and
thank you
to these accomplished physicians
and experts and public servants for
answering the call
to serve the american people in this
critical hour of need
over thanksgiving the president-elect
and i called
health care workers who are on the front
lines of this pandemic
just to thank them we wanted to express
our gratitude
and our nation's gratitude for
everything they have been doing
for every sacrifice they have made
that day i spoke with two registered
nurses
maureen in pennsylvania and talisa
in illinois they shared stories that
we've all heard
we've all heard the stories about
grandmothers and grandfathers
loved ones and friends spending their
last
moments alone we've all heard about
nurses and physicians
who are physically and mentally
exhausted
trying to keep up with ever increasing
caseloads
those on the front line who say to each
other
it's not a matter of when but it's a
matter not of when
but when when they will get the virus so
it is a matter of when and not if they
get the virus this is what they're
saying to each other every day
we've all heard about health care
workers without the supplies and
equipment they need
to care for patients and save lives
so today we have a message for talisa
maureen and all americans
help is on the way and it is long
overdue
the scale of this pandemic is
heartbreaking
as you know and have heard almost 15
million cases
more than 2 800 deaths in a single day
and then there is the economic
devastation
the lost jobs the small businesses
shuttered
not to mention what's happening to our
schools the parents and teachers who are
being
stretched to their limits and the toll
it's taking on the mental health and
well-being
of our children who risk each day
falling behind opening our schools and
economy
safely and responsibly getting this
virus under control
all of it starts with listening to
experts and leaders
like these americans who reflect
the very best of our nation they are top
physicians
public health experts and public
servants
and they are the team that the american
people need
and deserve to make sure testing and
treatment are free for everyone
to make sure vaccines are safe free
and equitably distributed to make sure
we
are better prepared for future pandemics
and other
health threats and to make sure quality
affordable health care is available to
all
from an early age i saw the life-saving
work that our health care professionals
provide
especially for the most vulnerable among
us
you see my mother was a breast cancer
researcher
and my sister and i spent many hours
roaming the hallways of the hospital
where she worked
i'm sure your kids have too and it's why
i actually
later co-founded an auxiliary group to
help patients at the county hospital in
oakland california
more than 20 years ago it's why we need
to protect and expand
the affordable care act and it's why we
have to listen
to front line health care workers like
maureen
and talisa in fact during our
conversation talisa said
we wouldn't send our soldiers to battle
without the gear they need
and we shouldn't then send our doctors
and our nurses except we kind of did
during the iraq war remember when
uh the the bush administration well
maybe some of you weren't following it
at the time
was under supplying soldiers that
we actually do do that we shouldn't but
everything we can
to save lives and contain this pandemic
once and for all getting this virus
under control is one of the defining
challenges of our time
and we will do what the american people
have always done in the face
of a great challenge we will
stand together and we
will defeat it thank you
and uh is that the full event
i guess it is or maybe not yes it is
there goes joe biden
all right we had the trump vaccine
propaganda event um
which seems to be continuing actually to
assess whether the vaccine is
efficacious or not
okay so now they're just doing other
elements of it we had we had it we had
both events we covered them i so
appreciate everybody joining me tonight
exclusive to twitch i'm getting a chess
lesson from grand master benjamin
feingold tonight i think it's 8
something eastern all right so join me
there
twitch.tv david pakman follow if you're
watching on twitch
subscribe if you're watching on youtube
i'll see everybody very soon